from Mata tomaron to faker and now ruler
only four players have had the honor of
being awarded an MVP award at Worlds so
we decided to take a look back at some
of the best plays that have helped these
individuals earned the highest honor and
league of legends
starting with mata imps infamous Botley
no play that's gonna show himself so
it's gonna push it out there the diamond
on corn in the mid lane and he's only
freight dead from that there is intake
though what can he do surely we'll be
able to finish our port is actually just
[Applause]
an attack now of trying to turn that
into eight larger straight flash away
benefits would be
the kill here that blade of the room
thing is down sit on too much more catch
potential but they do have to looper
so they can get into the jungle right
now but don't have were control they
can't have more control another hook
from matzoh they are going to be
everything that they need on the Kula
who would hopefully carry the game on
rise or it was going to be court moving
out on Ori he also goes down and pawn is
gonna be the one to pick that one up
looper is already scary though 4:03
about twenty five Cs haunting guys girly
social issues and now him and mats are
gonna look for something down the bottom
can they catch one our howling gale will
land up 2-0 boozy zero turn this one
around exhausted PhD he's put the
exhaust onto the support and it's gonna
clean up from this one zero will surely
fall trying to get the kill on the court
before he gets out of this one but
himself in front of the full and take
one for looper they're gonna continue
this fight a little bit as it comes in
out this one for the kills of the doctor
it's gonna be boxing with the hook
though towards the first one in in very
low on mana but auto attacks they don't
cost mana for the kills goal is just on
the chase with zero once blasted back
what a bunker shot
hip is now with the frame you know he
thought he was safe tech not grab the
lantern
[Applause]
[Applause]
to be tikis landed them on here for no
weight sitting the brush was spotted out
calling good and come through it's a lot
of damage left on to greens in there as
well they gonna be picking up more
killed as a reset come down once again
Darlington Google's Ward's a barren area
on Oh
roads caught out of position completely
here a great flash over from West Point
but that could be done it for Pond
rather exactly what he wants
Pearson's going to get knocked away now
they finalized the kill
[ __ ] from over the wall will get himself
up Ward down on the red book back at the
bottom explosive damage back and forth
that means they're gonna be through
along with the echo prism on a be taken
very low B if you place that equalizer a
little bit farther back
Oh going whoa that's a dress oh the oh
he's gonna be walking past the dark path
over man big damage comin out here if
you can actually get that blasting all
the bubble goes down ramada negative
be more trouble seesee yep is taking
shots pins even gonna get the reset on
the tank to get out once again their
boxer though is gonna be coming up its
of Mac Dre talk on towards that imp is
there as well the slow comes in
daddy appears from over the wall in the
kill is back over this wall it Felix
just like that three kills going over to
Samsung wife that was Motta's very
impressive 2014 World Championship
resume and now for 2015 MVP marrin
starting with this insane fiora play
against h2k well fake
even used the not is buckling a
challenger chef pink is going to be the
next focus Jana was able to kill faker
now Mar is looking for real and might
just find it challenges down Maria's
gonna stay alive ain't kids awake bang
left uncontested on the back line he
continued to attack wolf with a two-man
okapi on it get in the fight man no one
attacks down yet the boomerang goes I'm
not gonna fly a slow wide over the grill
Omari caught the mid lane though there's
a knock if this might be no there's
equalizer coming down at double-oh-seven
is taken out again coursers takes the
kill Oh Martha soul-stealer is a
different thing it's time for revenge
the flash employed used right away oh
sure where does let go right into a
flame chart claims spinner flames show
what back was that Maura same chompers
instantly it's easy for barn to boost
out a top mechanic in the top side of
the map just put long-faced a telephone
also much damaged a barn trying to chuck
him down he's got a lot of damage that's
what helped for spells will do it
there's the hit and why the solo kill
barring chasing down amazing J in the
top lane Maurin he's got the ulti Pop's
it so I was gonna be in a bad way - and
it's gonna be a flash follows only one
vital left Amar'e can't quite reach it
but against the slow but it's enough to
get more in the kill anyway but it will
delay Baron at least for now but here
comes Martin he finds expec a a
beautiful run post-ops the headbutt and
mid me was done so we could improve ur
eyes bolts for himself now Martin still
in the chase
here comes some damage from Niels but
the support might be going down it's a
big Chuck Martin barely survives they
wants a new pair of shoes and it's
crocodile skin the make they want
slice and dice is available for Marvin
and they get the Sun on - on and slices
and dices away on will follow with the
rocket jump Baker out if Mountain needs
that zip use all of a sudden out of
position decimate heel will not land and
zip will get dropped
mari can look for tunnel for a treat for
mountain flashes available just go th
get the D ports the bottom Martin got to
go all in let's take a look level 52
level 13 zips gonna be able to prop the
Grand Challenge noxian might will not
even get activated cheeky with all the
poke they try to do down on the turret
will branch out is up now oh dear Oh
warlock take it out create again at
least Darius hasn't actually by taxes
that's good it is the perfect item here
as well the one single a teleport for
amazing J is going to be canceled
bengi something and he comes in faker
he's gonna get stunned up tell applause
from both top lane is coming in as well
faith schools already down the Fox in a
fantastic position
EDG losing so much out there that dog
from our deaf still alive at the moment
is amazing Jay with a beat now was he
insane double kill now for this top line
up haha and gets dunked at the same time
in bangs just hopping everywhere little
accident towards the bot side the
teleport coming in right now from
his ultimate is up they lay down the
equalizer low should be able to get out
of this one barn into the fight now Kuro
and prey are the targets and that's
gonna be Kuro going down SKT seemingly
pulling this one back in their favor
with just a few kills to the baleen and
that's a double kill for Marit here SKT
cop on the hunt goes in that's gonna be
hojin in a real sticky situation he goes
down a full 3 mendoro to me that's gonna
be 2016 was the first year that SKT
seemed to have struggled on the world
stage but faker wasn't going to let his
team lose that tournament
so here fakers best plays from the 2016
World Championship starting with this
absolutely sick - man
Oriana ultimate against Samsung Galaxy
just easy gets dug gonna force her
[ __ ] pads offensively Bank a looking
to go with doesn't quite movie good the
bubbles get a nap - there as well break
it takes out sword out and I've been
exhausted still flashes own kites his
way back faker
still moving out does not go down a bank
he's gonna stretch forward SKT a
beautifully orchestrated play Oh take
her on an out there she's putting up a
bit in L the QSF to translate himself
but make it to be a lot of damage can I
come in for the kill very stylish Cuba
think he's dead trying to buy time but
they need that to get through the wave
Twitter the big dad's to give trundle
the extras - pushing past the poppy oh
and base like they're locked up faker
she gets kicked back here but a great
way from Nami keeps him out and SK
Telecom's to kill the Baron bang
rips sword art took pieces and Peggy's
gonna search for it pops around knew it
all deeper mercy Osama turn up and here
comes a TP thought up
thank you goes in pulses on these on top
of the gravity field in SK Telecom might
finally topple the black wolf casa
[ __ ] up Nexus Baker destroys n on the
side of maple he doesn't know what to do
if a bank closed him up as well getting
the double infernal Drake is just enough
to keep rocks in the game 2013 he
already took the rafters away he's
taking the drugs as well but now it's a
flashing gauge breaker he got a blue
buff back and Kuro stayed bid for far
too long they're closing and trying to
push the mid new wave person there goes
the counter-attack reprise the round
warm not gonna be enough to the cabarets
but the flash does now faker and wolf
here we go all five in the pit they want
to peel off they saw faker in the lane
he can't make it to fight immediately
they might just driver state it looks
like they're going for the first
ambition times back in it's secure
Samson get the Baron now they need to
win the fight ambition dives in GJ's not
just for JJ uses the algaas to stay
alive ambition ruler crab running for
their life they need to survive too
bengi plateau and his GJ's that prop
foolish the girl oughta hit points a lot
of mana but he doesn't have a lot of
support crown is down and rulers running
for his life goes to wolf however which
isn't the greatest distribution of goal
that fakers down both summoner spells
here call shin ambitions running in
gravity fields up that will stun a
vision under the tower kill is
my mission loses his life look for
hidden hands that are only so many
objectives this world
they're looking at kill
the only one alive if that was his life
and I believe he is the one wearing the
Buffalo he's not going to go up to this
side can heal and the kick though juice
juice away enough penis and help can
hear the beautiful disengaged port here
because he oh he's playing with four
Ward's of the map that's one extra for
Christmas wolf wolf no clues at all you
know rule CNS shockwave gonna read it
into everything nicely done s Kiki pick
one up that's fine drops Tigers have
been fighting around and you lose weight
quick foot spray into a trap as well and
the deletion is there nicely played
control the bottom side of this map
repeat a fresca tdd to poke down c9
before they fight here and suffice
they're playing a similar style as it a
playoffs
where does leave in fact on the island
oh great you're done again Franco
looking for the all ingested tough get
the stuff but wolf is here to complete
this just in their group again getting
it only by fake it that Ultimates easy
cleanup we're gonna try and save event
stinky grab the shot that would bring
Jude gonna get himself a goal for the
knocked off and gender response we got
trying to guide the D by cloud9 vitae
made something happen the bacon grab the
double
for the chaos impact find his way back
into the fight but I think you know how
he's got a little too far forward yeah I
can see exactly how strong impact jobs
down deep I was trough recited
interrupted it blank hanging around the
mid lane going on this could be the
fight Star Search his side step
shall we could be the target for the
void never cross this cord cocoon as
well slicing Mouseketeer on the board
they trade one for one
and now 2017 the finals MVP award was
given to ruler and this honor was very
well deserved especially for this insane
flash engage ulti against faker to take
Samsung to the finish line first
they've pot baker they've got the CC is
down the unkillable demon king of rulers
things in life killing in the backline
they found Boris Hootie does that have a
way out pops to go but he has no exit
route to a more audible kill him down
but he gets thrown away they twitch to
their aggro they knock down wolf instead
5b 3 in mid Turks is looking for Rula
through the wrong foods up brood prison
kept out some they kill you
Beck stays alive for a few seconds
longer rule effective full HP continues
to run
comes up a crowd trick get pop buds
again sell your private Rick still
trying to fire away on the sidewalk
what's your five-time
his death time g2 eSports get what get
Denny's and the outlaws by the few
seconds longer the are you man surviving
is expect that steps that make
quarterfinals ground charges up at your
end shield as we fire the trigger he
raised about to get excited by sever
from behind that's a duck down
to find some time roulette flashes
appeal to safety
you get one day IR into the wall triple
kill picked up for Allah Vince first
away to safety now she hates the target
ruler not gonna find the Quadra kill as
crowd takes him down and Shanghai is
silenced
that's another position fight
not too much though the old start down
here comes to regain once again for
ambition wants to add the damage
Colorado ruler
going to the feathers gonna be able to
call the feathers back Vincent galaxy
destroyer yes be solved in sitting on
the front line padding gets caught up by
the rupture force to run away he's
dodging jumping ducking and diving he
comes on to attack enough that Samsung
FFP
look at the suppression down it's a
mystic he's gonna get shut down keeps it
alive damn it stop the house you
unable to find anything to make saves
the day at Roulette turns it around we
don't know if he's recalled as the
business
[Applause]
ditching its focus onto Rua method rock
polcie a in place the point goes out as
well as the voice warned those crabs are
looking for blood conned equals to rent
defensively Sampson survived the engage
body Sam cuts up the audition
Gandhi stuff backward he's got no flash
available and through that gets his
boost to the game I have tank of the
front line don't be coming across
Ramirez will find a couple of roots of
the terrible pops his Locrian
vulnerability to re-engage and comes
Brown decanting feet touch pump himself
up for the slow and the first one comes
in his trundle drops a second as well as
buzz is gone the rockatuer for brother
wants a third they're gonna get a son I
pray he's to lose his life as well
number four and five next up of the
chopping block is beaten he could only
run away from the screen trying to find
a blank pad and could be in trouble he's
gonna get stunned up today enough time
before the hole comes out does not look
like an otter trying to get killed up
from a pushing forward onto the backline
it's frozen from the backside can defy
the studies
down samsung girl is for the turn rulers
leaping forward someone needed to step
up and Samsung have bounced their
opening cuvee flash support the pillar
dropping cooler looking for that head
that's out down there till for the ad
carry wait until they come to the leaf
woman now they're reading gates omnicons
is going to get low but pop tilts tail a
little bit logon I want a girl a trump
sound that is a dead work on the flash
poor the Thanh is that they're going to
get the next one and Frank is going to
fall as well the taste continues for a
ruler getting another rep double for
Astana and kuba gets the kill on top of
it was four four zero thanks for
watching if you want more great content
be sure to hit that subscribe button